- Thanks to Indochino for
keeping LegalEagle in the air
and helping me look fly.
(eagle squawking)
Justice Brett Kavanaugh's first term
as Supreme Court justice
has come to a close
and it was a big one
for the Supreme Court.
To recap, Justice Anthony
Kennedy retired in 2018,
leaving a very important
vacancy with the court.
Kennedy had been the court's swing vote.
Lawyers often tailored their arguments
specifically to Kennedy
since he was capable of siding
with the court's Liberal wing
or the court's Conservatives
depending on the specific issue.
There was wild speculation
as to whether the court
would start making a dramatic shift
now that it has a solid,
quote, Conservative majority,
and I'll note parenthetically
that the political alignments
of Conservative and Liberal
don't really hold up
when you're talking about
Supreme Court justices
but that's probably a
topic for another video.
On first blush, it looks
like Chief Justice Roberts
may be taking up the mantle
of the High Court's
centrist and deciding vote.
This term, the Supreme
Court has handed down
some big decisions on
partisan gerrymandering,
the census, profane trademarks, and more.
Now that the Supreme
Court's 2019 term has ended,
let's take a look at the
most consequential decisions.
(bright music)
Hey, LegalEagles!
Welcome back to Real Law Review
where today we're going to do a roundup
of what I consider the Supreme Court's
most consequential 2019 decisions.
So let's dig right in.
The first is the FUCT trademark,
which I am allowed to say on this channel
because it's spelled F-U-C-T,
not spelled any other way
so it's not a swear word.
So starting with the FUCT trademark case
which invalidated a federal
law that prohibited, quote,
immoral or scandalous
trademarks, whatever that means,
which, of course, is kind of the point
of this particular Supreme Court case.
For years, the US Patent and
Trademark Office or USPTO
has limited trademark protections
for things it deemed vulgar,
offensive, or scandalous
but in a victory for free
speech, the Supreme Court held
that the street clothing
called FUCT, F-U-C-T,
was entitled to federal
trademark protection.
That issue was the Trademark Act of 1905
which prohibits the registration
of immoral and scandalous trademarks.
However, under the First Amendment,
you can see where this is probably going,
the government can't
penalize a person's speech
because it disagrees with the
viewpoint being expressed.
Here, the viewpoint being swear words.
The Supreme Court held that
it's impossible for the USPTO
to decide what it considered
scandalous or immoral
without resorting to
viewpoint discrimination.
There is no coherent sense of these terms,
therefore the USPTO simply
applies its own sense
of what is right and wrong
and scandalous and what's not scandalous
which has some real
First Amendment problems.
The 1905 law has led to some
bizarre decisions by the USPTO.
For example, the government
granted a trademark
for the company that using
the word FCUK, F-C-U-K,
but denied it for FUCT, F-U-C-T,
even though both simply
play on the word (bleeps)
which we have to bleep because
that one is spelled F-U-C-K
because YouTube is more arbitrary
and capricious than the
USPTO at this point. (grunts)
Anyway, as a result,
a six-to-three majority
led by Justice Kagan
concluded that the prohibition
against the registration
of immoral or scandalous trademarks
violates the First Amendment.
The majority ruled that
The Lanham Act's bars
were substantially over broad.
As Justice Kagan noted,
"There are a great many immoral
"and scandalous ideas in the world,
"even more than there are swear words
"and the Lanham Act should cover them all.
"It therefore violates the First Amendment
"to deny trademark protection
to those kind of marks."
The court made a similar ruling in 2017
when it ruled that a band named The Slants
had a right to trademark its name.
The band used the term as
a way to reclaim a word
that is often used as
a slur against Asians.
That case wound up protecting
the Washington Redskins
after the USPTO canceled
the team's trademarks
after complaints that the word Redskins
was a racial slur
against Native Americans.
And while reasonable people can disagree
as to whether the term
Redskins is offensive or not,
we can all agree that we
should fire Dan Snyder,
#FireDanSnyder, #HireDavidChang.
But back to the case at hand,
Justices Roberts, Breyer,
and Sotomayor dissented
although they agreed that the
word immoral is over broad,
they thought the ban on
scandalous trademarks
is constitutional but just needs
to be more narrowly tailored.
The upshot of this decision
is that it's going to open the door
to all sorts of new and
interesting and profane trademarks
including many that probably
involve profanity in the
future, so (beeps) yeah.
♪ America (bleeps) yeah ♪
- Racist jury selection.
The court handed a big win
to advocates of unbiased jury
trial by ordering a new trial
for the death row inmate Curtis Flowers
who has been tried six times
over the past two decades.
In the American justice
system of jury trials,
both sides get an opportunity
to strike a limited
number of jurors for cause
such as conflicts of interest.
The parties also get to strike
a certain number of jurors
for any reason whatsoever.
These are what are known
as peremptory challenges.
There is one huge caveat, though.
The attorneys cannot use
their peremptory strikes
for racial reasons to
prevent potential jurors
from being selected because of their race.
This is called a Batson Challenge
which we've talked about
on this channel before.
It goes back to the Supreme Court case
of Batson versus Mississippi.
In the Flowers case,
district attorney Doug Evans
allegedly used peremptory
strikes to dismiss black jurors
from a jury pool in all
six of Flowers' trials.
Evans eliminated 41
out of 42 black jurors.
The 72 majority opinion
written by Justice Kavanaugh
included that the state's pattern
of striking prospective black jurors
persisted from Flowers'
first trial through his sixth
and this was a relentless effort
to stop the jury from
having any black jurors
which strongly indicated that Evans
was trying to try Flowers
before the whitest jury he
could possibly find and create.
The majority noted that
the prosecutors questioned
the black and white
prospective jurors differently.
For example, they gave 145 questions
to just five perspective black jurors.
They asked only 12 questions
to the 11 white jurors seated
for Flowers' most recent trial.
The prosecutor and his team
struck at least one
black prospective juror
who was similarly situated
to white prospective jurors
who were not struck by the state.
So the Flowers case extends the doctrine
that was created in
Batson versus Mississippi
that you cannot use
your peremptory strikes
to strike all or most of the black jurors
from a prospective jury
pool which is exactly
what happened in the John
Grisham book and movie,
A Time to Kill.
I'll put a link down to my
review in the description.
The hotly-debated census citizenship case.
The US Constitution requires The US
to conduct a census every 10 years.
This is incredibly important
for political districting purposes.
The census counts every
person in the county
and is used to appropriate federal funds,
draw electoral districts,
and apportion representatives
to the various states.
In March of 2018, Secretary
of Commerce Wilbur Ross
added a question to the 2020 census
which required each person
to state whether they
are a US citizen or not.
Ross claimed that the Trump administration
added the question because it was keen
to enforce Federal voting rights laws
to better protect minority
and voting rights.
This rationale seemed pretty
suspect from the start
since the Trump administration
has never filed a lawsuit
to enforce the Voting Rights Act
and that rationale ran contrary
to a lot of the actual language
coming out of the Trump administration
and from President Trump himself.
The outcome of this case turned on
whether the Voting Rights Act
was really the government's motive
for asking the citizenship
question or not,
because generally, the courts
don't dispute the rationale
that the government puts forward.
But under the Administrative
Procedure Act,
any agency action that is, quote,
arbitrary or capricious violates the law.
Moreover at a minimum,
an agency must disclose
the basis of its action so
courts can review its legality.
Several states sued
the Commerce Department
and argued that the question
was arbitrary and capricious
and it was a move designed solely
to isolate and marginalize
people of color,
particularly Latinos
who may be undocumented
which would under count the
population in many US states,
particularly in the Southwest.
The plaintiffs feared that the question
would deter many Latinos from
answering the census question
because they would fear deportation.
The government argued it
was simply a return to form
because from 1820 to 1950,
the census included a
citizenship question.
The government also questioned
whether anyone had actual
standing to sue over the question
and said that the notion
that people would not answer
the question truthfully
was based on sheer speculation
because the question
hadn't been issued yet.
The plaintiffs contended that according
to the government's own records,
the citizenship question
would lead to an under count
of at least five million people.
This was the government's
conclusion after the 1950 census
which is why the government
dropped the question
in the first place.
The plaintiffs prevailed
in the lower courts
which ruled that Ross's
actions were arbitrary
and capricious based on pretext
and violated parts of the Census Act.
The district court concluded
that Ross had exceeded his authority
in crafting the question
because of its illegality.
The Commerce Department
appealed to the Supreme Court.
Now, the Supreme Court narrowly
sided with the plaintiffs
in a five-to-four decision
with chief justice casting the swing vote.
The court first overruled portions
of the lower court decision.
The majority of justices found
that Secretary Ross had the authority
to draft the census question
and was within his right as agency head
to seek records and data.
However, Roberts concluded
that the rationale Ross gave
for the question,
wanting to help minorities
exercise their voting rights,
was quote contrived.
Although agencies have
broad authority to regulate,
they must offer genuine reasons
for the decisions that they make.
Secretary Ross's reason
for seeking the data
that he wanted to improve
voting rights access
appeared to play no actual
role in his decision.
In fact, Ross first
inquired about reinstating
the citizenship question
just one week after his appointment.
According to Justice Roberts,
altogether the evidence tells a story
that does not match the
secretary's explanation
for his decision.
In other words,
Ross's reason for asking the
question was pre-textual.
The court ruled that for now,
the question could not go forward.
However, the opinion leaves the door open
for the government to
bring back the question
if they can come up with
another justification
for seeking that
information in the census,
which takes us to a similar
case with a different outcome,
that on partisan gerrymandering.
Partisan gerrymandering is
when one political party
draws the district maps at
the other party's expense,
making it easier for the party
in power to stay in power.
The States use census
data to draw up new maps
portioning representatives
to state legislators
in federal districts.
For many years, the political party
with the most power in the states
have drawn districts into strange shapes
that make it easier for
incumbents to hold on to power.
So can state officials ever go so far
in drawing partisan districts
that it violates the US Constitution?
That was the question
before the Supreme Court
in this most recent case.
Justice Kennedy was the
swing vote back in 2004
when the Supreme Court's
Conservative justices plus Kennedy,
whether you consider
him Conservative or not,
ruled that the Supreme
Court should stay out
of a contentious gerrymandering
case from Pennsylvania.
However, Kennedy left the door ajar,
stating that in a future case,
it could be possible for
one party to skew maps
so much that it was unconstitutional.
The problem that Kennedy identified
was that there seemed to
be no workable standard
for determining when gerrymandering
was unconstitutional.
However, with Kennedy's swing vote gone,
the court's Conservatives easily prevailed
in the two cases involving
partisan gerrymandering
in North Carolina and
Maryland during this term.
In a five-to-four decision
written by Chief Justice Roberts,
the Supreme court said
that the Federal Courts
now lacked jurisdiction
to even hear partisan
gerrymandering cases.
Roberts declared partisan
gerrymandering as, quote,
"Nothing new and a traditional
part of partisan politics."
Roberts and the other four
Conservative justices ruled
that the case was not justiciable
and that it runs afoul of the
Political Question Doctrine.
By the way, background,
when a case presents a,
quote, political question,
Federal Courts will
refuse to hear the case.
The legal doctrine was developed
to prevent Federal Courts
from intervening in disputes
that are so politically charged
that the courts feel that they
should just stay out of them
and let the legislatures deal
with those particular questions.
Here, the majority held that
partisan gerrymandering claims
present political questions
beyond the reach of the Federal Courts
which brings us to the court's opinion
in Gamble versus The United States,
dealing with the Dual
Sovereignty Doctrine.
The Dual Sovereignty Doctrine
is a pretty arcane piece of jurisprudence
but it generated lots of attention
because the media covered it
as if it posed the following question.
Could a person connected to Donald Trump,
like convicted felon Paul Manafort
receive a pardon for federal charges
but still be prosecuted in the state court
for the same things?
However, the case pending before the court
did not involve Manafort or
any Trump-related official
but it might have implications
into those individuals.
There's a legal doctrine which holds that
because the federal and state governments
are, quote, separate sovereigns,
the Double Jeopardy Clause does not apply
to prosecution of the same crime
under both federal and state laws.
This is known as the
Separate Sovereigns Doctrine.
So the question is can a
person wind up facing state
and federal prosecutions
for the same conduct
or does that violate the
Double Jeopardy Clause
of the Fifth Amendment?
In the case at hand,
Terence Gamble was convicted
under Alabama state criminal law
for being a felon in possession of a gun.
He was also prosecuted
under a federal criminal law
for being a felon in
possession of a gun as well.
He appealed his federal conviction
citing the Double Jeopardy Clause.
Gamble lost his appeal in the lower courts
and the Supreme Court considered the case.
The Supreme Court's
seven-to-two majority decision
affirmed that Double Jeopardy
did not bar Gamble's conviction.
Justice Alito wrote the majority opinion
that there was no reason
to overturn the Dual Sovereignty Doctrine.
The Double Jeopardy Clause
bars successive prosecutions
for the same offense,
not for the same conduct.
That means that Gamble
could not be tried twice
for the same violation of
the Alabama Criminal Codes
but he could be tried again
for arguably the same underlying conduct
in both federal and state courts.
So while the majority of opinion
certainly will do nothing
to advance the cause of
criminal justice reform
and most defendants to be
tried by the Federal Government
and the state government will
probably just be regular Joes
like Terrence Gamble,
it does mean that any person Trump pardons
for a federal offense can
still be tried in state court.
Unconscious and emergency
searches and seizures.
Another criminal justice
case from this term
placed some additional
limits on your rights
under the Fourth Amendment.
Six years ago, police found
Gerald Mitchell soaking wet
and sloppy drunk in a
sandy beach in Wisconsin.
He was shirtless and slurring his words.
He took a preliminary breath test
which indicated his blood alcohol level
was three times the legal limit.
Since this test was ineligible
to be used in court,
police had to decide how
to get admissible evidence
of Mitchell's condition.
They took him to a
hospital for a blood test.
There was just one hitch.
Mitchell passed out in the
backseat of the squad car
on the way to the hospital
but the hospital staff drew his blood
while he was knocked out
which indicated a blood
alcohol level of 0.222.
The police never obtained a warrant.
Mitchell tried to get the results
of the blood test thrown out
arguing that the cops needed a warrant
but Wisconsin state law
says the drivers on his road
presumably consent to a blood test.
The Supreme Court justices
ruled five to four
that the Fourth Amendment
generally does not stop states
from taking a blood
sample without a warrant
if the suspect is unconscious.
The Fourth Amendment to the
Constitution protects your right
to unreasonable searches and seizures
and it states that both
the right of the people
to be secure in their persons,
houses, papers, and effects
against unreasonable searches and seizures
shall not be violated and
no warrants shall issue
but upon probable cause.
While the general rule is
that police need a warrant,
there are many exceptions to this rule.
One of the exceptions
is called the Exigent
Circumstances Exception
which lets police search without a warrant
to prevent the imminent
destruction of evidence.
Evidence of a person's blood alcohol level
disappears over time
as it is absorbed through the bloodstream.
The Supreme Court said
that if police waited
until an unconscious person is awake,
then the evidence that
they were intoxicated
could be destroyed which allows police
to now draw blood from you
if you are unconscious,
without a warrant.
The Bladensburg Peace Cross.
The Bladensburg Peace Cross
is a nearly century-old
monument in Maryland
to those who died in World War I.
The cross sits on a traffic island
that is public land in
Bladensburg, Maryland.
The cross is associated with
Christianity, obviously,
so the American Humanist
Association filed a lawsuit
alleging that the cross's
presence on public land
violated the First Amendment's
Establishment Clause.
The court's religion cases
have recently given the
government wide latitude
to include religious
references on state property
and material as long as they
can be branded as, quote,
ceremonial or celebratory
or commemorative.
For example, the court has ruled
that the words In God We Trust
should remain on the US currency
over the objection of non-theists.
The court reasoned that the message
is of historical importance
and is now merely ceremonial
rather than religious.
The same is true of the
statement One Nation Under God,
another Christian reference,
that the court says does not run afoul
of the Establishment Clause.
Alito wrote, "A government
that roams the land,
"tearing down monuments
with religious symbolism
"and scrubbing away any
reference to the divine
"will strike many as aggressively
hostile to religion."
Justices Ginsburg and Sotomayor dissented.
Ginsberg wrote, "Just as the Star of David
"is not suitable to honor Christians
"who died serving their country,
"so a cross is not suitable
to honor those of other faiths
"who died defending their nation."
The court appears to be drawing a line
between symbols and monuments
which have been in place for many years
and those which may be
erected in the future.
Alito's argument probably
gave a little bit of life
to people who are angry about
the removal of old monuments.
However, commentators are split
on what that means for new monuments.
Now, if you're ever going to try a case
before the Supreme Court,
you'll need to get a great-looking suit.
As evidenced by this footage
from inside the Supreme Court,
all the lawyers are dressed to the nines.
I'm just kidding,
the Supreme Court does
not allow video recording
and the lawyers generally dress
in suits that are four
sizes too big for them.
Still, I would recommend
getting a slim cut,
fully-custom suit from Indochino.
Indochino.
All of my suits are now
custom-made by Indochino,
including this three-piece
suit that I'm wearing right now
with a custom double-breasted
vest which I think is awesome.
Indochino will make
you a fully-custom suit
tailored specifically to
you for less than $400.
And the best part is they
still use the best materials
like Super 140 wool and cashmere.
In fact, I reached out to Indochino
to ask them to guarantee that LegalEagles
would get the best price and
they were happy to oblige.
And I am happy to report that LegalEagles
get the exclusive ability to
buy any premium Indochino suit
which is their most popular suit for 359.
That is the best deal
you will find anywhere on the internet.
Personally, I will never buy
an off-the-rack suit again.
You have tons of choices too
because the secret to a great
suit is all about the fit.
I'm a reasonably athletic guy
and I can never buy suits off the rack
because they just simply never fit right.
But with Indochino,
you can either send your
measurements in online
or you can go to a physical store
and have a stylist at Indochino
take your own measurements
which is what I did when I
had a stylist work with me
for over 90 minutes to take
every measurement possible.
We added my measurements into the system
and a couple of weeks later,
I got the best-fitting
suit of my entire life.
It was perfect right out of the box.
LegalEagles can get any premium
Indochino suit for just 359
when you enter the code
LegalEagle at checkout
or use the link in the description.
Clicking on the link really
helps out this channel.
That's Inodochino.com,
promo code LegalEagle,
for the best custom suit
of your entire life.
So do you agree with my
Supreme Court summaries?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other
Real Law Reviews over here
where we tackle all
of the important legal issues of the day.
Click on that playlist and
I will see you in court.